BRADY HARAN: Hi there,
everyone.
I'm on holiday at the moment.
But like any numberphile, I'm
thinking about numbers.
And I've been so impressed with
all the one-roll Yahtzees
you've been sending in, I've
decided to up the ante.
So I've got some dice here.
I'm going to go for another
one-roll Yahtzee.
But have a look at this.
I'll show you where I'm
going to do it.
I'm going to need this.
That's a bit of a clue.
Got my flippers, and there
is the Indian Ocean.
That's where I'm going to go
for my underwater Maldivian
one-roll Yahtzee.
So while I head on out to sea,
here are the latest videos
from you, the viewers.
Firstly, DoodleChaos.
A fan of Rube Goldberg machines,
came up with this
inspired contraption.
And then went a step further.
We know there's a 1 in 1,296
chance of rolling five
matching dice.
A sixth matching dice,
1 in 7,776.
But it's no dice this
time, I'm afraid.
And I'm still struggling
under water.
Here are some people who
were more successful.
MALE SPEAKER: Yes!
MALE SPEAKER: Oh my God.
Oh my God.
MALE SPEAKER: Whoo!
MALE SPEAKER: So this is for
Numberphile, [INAUDIBLE]
[LAUGHING]
MALE SPEAKER: Yahtzee.
MALE SPEAKER: Yes!
MALE SPEAKER: [INAUDIBLE]
Yahtzee, woo.
Yahtzee.
BRADY HARAN: This isn't
proving easy.
Maybe some homemade software
is the key.
Now I mentioned how tough a
six dice Yahtzee is, but
here's someone who did it.
Not everyone's so lucky.
Here's someone who never
got a Yahtzee but
still sent in the video.
And you know what, even
migrating to dry land now, I
don't seem to be having
much luck either.
Stay tuned to Numberphile
though, because we do have
more videos coming, including
a very special Yahtzee
contribution from someone
you may recognize.
VIHART: Yo, Brady.
It's ViHart.
And as promised, I'm going
to throw you a Yahtzee.
BRADY HARAN: That's definitely
going to
be one worth watching.
Here's the link to all our
previous Yahtzee videos.
But I promise the next
Numberphile video, that won't
have any dice at all because,
well, frankly, I'm sick of the
sight of them.